hey hi
i'm uh christopher osanovic i'm one of
the people who's been working on risk
five
i should give a shout out to all the
major contributors especially
andrew warden and jensep lee two of our
grad students who uh
drove a lot of this and dave patterson
who's in the audience has been working
with me on this as well
there's a whole host of characters have
been helping with risk five in the
aspire lab
ok so let's get started so i start with
a little aside here which is
my first computer this is a picture of
my first computer now in the uk
i ask people to guess what this is i'll
ask here i don't expect anybody to know
this
um now this was actually an acorn
atom so it came out before the bbc micro
there's a 6502 base machine and there's
two reasons
i'm telling you about this machine one
is that
it was open source and you bought the
computer you got the schematics you knew
exactly
what was in there made it very easy to
program it attach stuff to it
play with it the second reason it's made
by acorn
and people have tried to cast risk five
versus armors david versus goliath
i find that pretty funny young guys
think it's funny too because they think
they're david fighting
the other goliath intel um but um really
i just want to say a few things about
arm this is kind of a disclaimer that
you know they're a great company
they produce if they produce the ip you
need um
and if you can work out a license
agreement with them in time
um then you'd be crazy not to use arm
but many projects don't fit into the
above and some people
are just crazy so
what does an isa well the first thing i
should say about isa is they don't
matter at all right isas are really
really unimportant in the grand scheme
of things and by that i mean if you look
at
the performance and efficiency of a
system
um most of it's due to other stuff like
the algorithm you use
much bigger weight on how well a system
performs than anything about instruction
set
how you code it um a compiler you use
there is a little effect from the isa
maybe
um but the micro architecture the core
design the memory hierarchy
the circuit design how good your design
is building these components
the physical design how well did you do
floor planning
the fabrication you use to build this
thing right so intel's got amazing
fabrication technology
so in some sense i says don't really
matter if you look at performance energy
efficiency
right um and this is what
some people wonder about why do we care
about isa anymore because of all these
other factors
but the reason that isas do matter is
that
um it's the most important interface in
a computer system it's where hardware
meets software
okay and um there's a massive cost to
port and tune
all the isa dependent parts of a
software stack
um just one small example rb8 still
doesn't have a very effective jvm
right so um and as well as that there's
all the stuff you don't expect like the
large cost of port and tune and quality
are short
as sure all the stuff that's supposed to
be isa independent
but turns out it isn't because all the
other stuff usually has bugs in that isa
depart
that board so there's a lot of work to
bring everything over
to a new isa okay so
given that um if the choice of isa
doesn't have much impact on the end
system's energy performance
and it costs a lot to use different ones
why is there more than one right makes
no sense the industry has more than one
isa right so why is that okay
um so we say no reason there should be
one i say it should be free and open
should be standard just like ethernet
right just kind of way you connect parts
the industry together the hardware guys
the software guys
um so so why is why are we in a
situation where there are multiple
different isas
well it's basically historical and
business reason there's no technical
reason
for the lack of a free and open isa um
it's not an error of a mission
it's not like those guys at intel and um
just wake up one morning and say oh you
know what we forgot to do
we forgot to make our eyes they open you
know it's like you know they wake up oh
yeah we'll go do that right now you know
tax their underlings to go and make it
open to everybody
they will actively go and sue you if you
try and do an implementation
of you know intel core or an arm core or
an ibm power
or any of these other isas right they'll
aggressively go after anybody trying to
do an implementation
and to that standard so it's not that
they just forgot to do this right
they go out there and get people who try
and do this um
now the other reason why is it
proprietary is it because these guys
develop all the software for you as well
no i mean most of the software for an
isa isn't written by the companies who
shall
sell parts for that i say it's done by
other people like all the developers out
there
do all that software development right
um
and it's not because these are great
isas
right you know like these are the only
people who could ever come up with
something as wonderful as their
creations like x86
on v7 v8 right it's you know is that why
we chose those isas because they're so
great
um they're just not the most the the
best isa in the world if you wanted to
do and i say you would not pick one of
those right it's just what's out there
what they got right so they're not the
wonderful isis either
one other piece of fud we hear from you
know people who are promoting the
license that i say is
well you know our company will guarantee
compatibility for you make sure the
hardware runs stuff
um isa is one of the easiest things to
verify compared to
other industry standards like wi-fi you
know
lte this other stuff this is like
trivial
right making sure is a compatible it's
an important thing you want to have it
be there
it's not anywhere near difficult enough
to require a billions of dollar
investment in a company to do this right
you could have small labs certifying isa
compatibility it's much simpler and lots
of other things for which the industry
has open
interfaces and has people verifying
compatibility and things work together
okay so there's no technical reason why
i say shouldn't be free and open
is purely historical and business
reasons why these things have been
locked up
another big issue and one that impacts
those as researchers is those
proprietary isas are not guaranteed to
last
some of you may remember a pretty large
computer company called digital
equipment corporation
right and they had some pretty important
isas at one point vax and alpha
they're both gone right if you build all
that software you spend the billions
shooting your stuff for their isas and
for some bad business decisions that
company the company goes under
what do you do with your software while
you move it to a different isa
that's a big cost and as researchers i
know that a lot of researchers for
example built research infrastructure
around the digital alpha i say it's kind
of
relatively nice and clean that's all
gone and what's worse is you cannot
choose to keep it going
because there's probably some small ip
holding firm that has the stuff and will
go after you
because it was proprietary it seemed to
be worth something right
so um the proprietary isa is a guarantee
i guarantee that intel x86 will not be
around indefinitely
at some point it will be replaced right
same with arm
right every isa will die
eventually um so they're not guaranteed
to last
that's another thing and you can't
choose to maintain them
afterwards necessarily if they've been
proprietary um
so let's say we actually had a viable
freely open isa what would the benefits
be
well um we believe one of the big things
would just be greater innovation
from many many core designers so you got
a standard
companies could compete on the quality
of their implementation
rather the aggress rather than the
aggressiveness of their lawyers right
they could actually compete on the
quality of what they built
and we think that would allow many many
core designs it would also support
open source core designs right now you
know you cannot
if you do all the work yourself put an
arm v7 v8 core out there
and have other people look at it and try
to improve it that's just not allowed
you'll be
you'll get take down notice straight
away okay
another thing that some entities find
a little discomforting about buying
proprietary i say implementations is
they don't trust
the countries that those companies work
in and to produce things that don't have
trap doors in so if you're
you know the chinese government indian
government african government i don't
know if you'd want to trust the uk or
the u.s companies
to give you a core that didn't have
trapdoors in and this is a real issue
and
you know revelations the last few years
you know stuff goes on that you wouldn't
imagine actually went on
and so these are not just the tinfoil
hat brigade these are serious people in
other governments worrying about
trapdoors in these designs
um now cost of licensing these is
actually probably one of the minor
issues
there is a if you actually negotiate a
deal the cost
is not burdensome but the time to
negotiate the deal and some of the
upfront costs
matter and so if you're smart start-ups
in the newest hottest thing here at
stanford you're all
you know money-grubbing capitalists you
know that's the berkeley view anyway so
yeah well your startup ideas you want to
get ideas out there quickly
um the time to negotiate the agreement
and the upfront money may stop you doing
it be nice to have something you can
quickly use without thinking about it
to get your idea off the ground because
usually that's not a critical component
in your grand idea
you just need a core that kind of runs
all the software right
um and for us the original motivation
was to make
architecture education and research more
real so actually have real things that
you know
we could fabricate we could run code on
we could pour stacks to and make it more
real than
sort of toy simulators that kind of only
just model uh one of these hardware
things and also if we invest all this
work in our you know infrastructure we
don't want it to disappear when the
company goes under like
like what happened with dec okay um
so we all agree we need a free and open
isa so which one we're going to use
so what style of isa well if the isa
doesn't really matter too much in terms
of end system energy performance
as implementers you want to pick one
that's easy to implement right there's
no reason to go to something like an x86
you'd want to do something relatively
simple and you know see more craze load
store designs later refining the risk
those seem like a great choice those
design ideas have survived many
generations of technology
and seemed like a a sensible place uh
to you know put your stake in the ground
so this looks like but you know risk
style i say seems to be the iso you want
to build to make it open standard right
so it should be a risk that i say
now we're not the first people to think
about doing a free and open wrist style
i say there's been a bunch of others
so one to give us credit spark v8 um sun
microsystems
uh actually made spark v8 and ieee
standard an open standard you could go
down the spec i think it was 99 to get a
license to build them
very cheap so and there's actually sun
also actually put out open source cores
that um for v8 and some for v9 even um
that were open and available for people
to use there's a a company in
europe geisler they offer some open
source cores that match v8 as well
so that's one example that's already
been done um
open risk is a large effort started by a
group of slovenian undergraduates
in 1999 who apparently took dave's book
and
dave and john's book and typed in the
dlx description to verilog
modified it slightly and that's the open
risk core
that's gone through a couple generations
um
so that one's been out there for a while
there's a small community built around
that and many
actually several socs have been built
using that open risk core
a more recent one we just heard about
was the open processor foundation
this is uh folks are involved with the
hitachi
sh risk architecture and in japan it
turns out that you know hitachi's no
longer interested in pushing that the
patents are expiring
and so some of the designers of people
are trying to push that out as an open
source available
core for people to use um another
example i just
uh been hearing a lot about lately is
this lattice micro 32
they have a 32-bit simple risk software
that's available for anybody to
download and use so there are a bunch of
open we're not the first people to think
of one
there's a bunch out there why do we do
something different well
um when we started there is five project
um
this was back in 2010 so my group you
know dave's groups lots of previous
projects we've worked on many different
isas
commercial ones our own ones and
sort of basically every so often you sit
down and say for the next big research
infrastructure
what i say am i going to use so back in
we sort of did that what are we going to
use for the next bunch of projects um so
the obvious choices at that time were
you know intel x86 or r those are the
two choices so you sat down look at
these
and so you crack open the x86 manual
what's the first op code
aaa so what's aaa
yeah ascii adjust after addition right
so how you turn your bcd thing and the
low nibble into something that you can
you know carry add six and carry the
high bit you know when you look at that
and you say there's no way i'm going to
implement
this isa um so the x80
is easy to figure that out right that's
good they put that first because you
know
here be dragons right so so x86 just
impossible right so it's way too
complicated for anybody to consider
implementing now
and there's all the ip issues right you
really couldn't do this anyway even if
you wanted to
um so then we looked at arm the other
choice it's a risk architecture if you
look at it
you say well you know to paraphrase
douglas adams this is kind of mostly
impossible right so
it's you know very complicated also um
it's definitely not a lean risk
design um and massive ip issues yep
64 bit is a little better except it's
not much better because it includes a
32-bit
so it's strictly greater than the 6 you
know this 32-bit
um so and the 32-bit includes several
isas not just one
right so way way complicated you've
actually wanted to
why would you want to use these it's
because you want to use a software stack
if you want to use the arm software
stack
you've got to do a lot of work to bring
things up right so this is you know
mostly impossible
complex a lot of ip issues when we
started this we didn't we thought there
were ip issues
since then we've learned a lot about yes
there are very very very serious ip
issues with
other issues okay so in the summer 2010
we decided like a you know a three-month
project
um to develop our own clean slate isa
right so you know four years later um
we released the uh the frozen now frozen
user level uh isa specification but it's
not like we just sat down
broke the spec for four years and then
shipped it we
over those four years we've actually did
many silicon implementations
did drafts got rounds of feedback from
people outside of
berkeley and so it's evolved a lot and
being cleaned up over time
with input from many many people not
just folks at berkeley
um yep this is tampere what about mix
and fx yeah um
those i categorize as not being real
isas you would use for harder
implementation
would say otherwise we'd love to see a
silicon
right i i think you yeah i looked at
those a while ago
um they're not really designed for the
kind of purposes we're designed for
so were there protective modes uh that
were
tentative uh in these implementations or
were they yeah
good linux for example so they didn't
have a simplifies anymore
yeah i'll talk about that later okay
okay
okay so one thing i'll say risk five is
not an open source processor
right risk 5 is a specification for an
isa
there happen to be people building open
source processors to the risk 5 isa spec
including ourselves
but there are many other groups building
those cores for all i know there are
well actually i do know of at least one
company building their own core
proprietary which is fine so the point
is risk five is about an interface
specification
that's the biggest part of the project
we happen to be also doing cores and
chip generators that people can use
right so it's an isa spec and i think
the important thing
um when people talk about open source
hardware i've sort of been realizing
that the kind of bug in how people think
about this
the real hard part about building
hardware is the software
and the thing people do wrong when they
attack at all source hardware project is
they focus on the hardware
right so you got these hardware that
doesn't matter like all the cost is in
the software development
if you're building a chip most of the
software is completely independent of
your special widget on that chip
so what you want to have is open source
hardware generator that generates the
hardware that
for which most of the software already
exists or almost all of the software
like 99.99 of it is already there
you don't have to touch it that would
dramatically lower the cost of doing new
hardware startups right
there's a standard specification for
most of the software stack you just had
to worry about the little widget you
added
um to that so we're also expanding there
is five spec
out to cover as well as a supervisor
level things like how io is handled
how other parts of the chip are handled
how accelerators are plugged in so the
point is to build this out to a full
spec
of what target soc should look like and
again
actually the implementation piece is is
great but that's not
actually the primary thing the thing is
if you get this spec nail down people
agree to it
everybody can build stuff everybody can
share stuff but you can build
proprietary implementations and you can
much lower the barrier to entry to
people doing new hardware design
so the way to get better more hardware
startups is allow them to use open
source software
right that's the trick okay um
so let's dive into what is risk five um
so when designing this we wanted to make
this an isa that worked for everything
from very small to very large processes
also very important was he wanted the
isa to be a base
to support custom accelerators extension
so you want to add your
you know build a special engine to do
whatever we wanted to let you be able to
use wrist five as a base and in
particular
to reuse a software infrastructure
around risk five when extending it and
adding new things
so there are actually three base integer
iss
um depending on the address width you
want in the system so this rv 32i
is the 32-bit address space rb64i is a
64-bit address space
and rv 128 is 128-bit address-based
version
right in the first drafts we kind of
added that in as a kind of a joke like
yeah here's 128-bit version
because it fit our instruction template
our design pattern worked
for that as well and we'd read in uh you
know some very famous people while back
said the only mistake and isa can't
recover from is not having enough
address bits
so you want to make sure that wasn't no
issue subsequently in talking to people
this is perhaps closer in than most
people think
some of the data center clusters have
solid state stores they actively using
in production of 10 petabytes
that's 54 bits of addressing right now
it's not directly addressed as memory
right now but people are working on much
faster networks
um different ways of looking at it you
never want to densely pack an address
space with stuff
so sometime next decade there might be a
need for 120
or more than 64-bit addressing at the
data center scale when we have solid
state memories that are that big
okay so we're ready you know we already
have the isa defined
um ready to go the nice thing about this
base integer isa for all three of those
is the base is only 40 hardware
instructions you need to implement
and those are selected so nobody in the
right mind would choose to subset and
omit them
any of those right and the nice thing
about those 40 there is enough to run a
modern software stack so gcc
uh dynamic linking big code running at
os
you don't need more than that to do all
those functions so when you want to
build an accelerator
we think you'd be kind of crazy to
define your own isa you should just take
this one and extend it
and you can start with a full compiler
suite on from the get-go
right so and that's all you need to
implement and it's very very simple
on top of that we split the extension
mode into sort of standard extensions
which we
help define and make sure don't conflict
with themselves and
other future standard extensions and
non-stand extension standard extensions
we can do whatever you want right
so the standard extensions are very
defined at what we call mafd
m is integer multiply divide a is
atomics
for a multiprocessor support um f is
single precision floating point d is
double precision floating point
so this combination of imafd we call g
and we view that as being a very good
general purpose
isa instructions they include all the
protected privilege each state no so
yeah question the question was do those
include the supervisor so
um we were very clean this was reading
lots of i say manuals has been thing
i've been doing a lot lately
it's it's surprising to me how much they
mix up
supervisor stuff and micro architecture
with the isa specification
in risk five we're very clear to
separate out user level stuff
from both the supervised level stuff and
the microarchitecture
makes the isa description much simpler
and avoids polluting people's heads with
weird ideas about what matters in the
isa so the isa is very much agnostic to
supervisor or
privileged mode i'll talk a little about
privilege mode in a minute
yep is the instruction set virtualizable
yes that was one of the design goals
it's designed to be classically
virtualizable
so you can run a guest os at user level
and all the traps will happen as you
expect
so yeah that was a design goal i'll talk
about that in a minute
so so this g is what we think of as a
pretty good general purpose instruction
set and that's now frozen
and the idea is we're going to preserve
this forever so you know
in the future and if you want one one
goal here is not to keep adding
instructions to this one
bug i see in rsa designs is people keep
adding instructions
so that means a future implementer has
to add all these extra instructions even
if they didn't really need them
most instructions that get added only
help a certain class of programs
they may help them a lot but they only
help a certain class of programs beyond
this base set
it's very hard to add an instruction
that helps almost any every application
don't you think there will still be
instructions they won't help all
programmers but will help enough in
certain cases
that they're required that you really
want them like for example the various
fence instructions have been added to
the intel
architecture those are really important
for doing visualization uh what about
i'm not as familiar with these but there
are new instructions in the next
generation of intel
chips that will use cash coherence to do
locking even more efficiently than we
could
today it just seems like people are
continually discovering new things that
could have a major impact
you think that no history is done the
age of progress is over
eric it's very educational to look at on
v8 and see what they threw out
over the year and look at where they
where everybody and if you look at mips
r6 that just released my imagination
you go look at what's happening
everybody's converged back to pretty
simple set of instructions fences and
atomics
are very important and actually the base
i say one of those
40 instructions is a fence um but the
atomics are pulled out separately
because one of the applications is deep
embedded we only have one core and it
talks to everything else through fifos
you don't actually need the atomics
so the transactional memory is one that
we didn't put in this g
because i view that as not baked yet so
people haven't quite figured out what
that should be it's an extension so our
goal is we mandate you know we have
these base that
that work and they're fixed you have
extensions to add things on and we want
to support
a large number of extensions later but
we want also to not
um get away from this course when you
don't need that other stuff you don't
have to implement it the tools will be
there to support you
in doing that i think the important
important thing to separate out is
people building future general purpose
platforms from people developing
embedded specialized systems these are
two communities with quite different
needs
but there's no reason for them to have
substantially different isis
yeah so i think this is the important
thing that chris has done is he's made a
modular instruction set
that with socs you can pick the pieces
you want and there's room for growth in
the future but that has
this part has to be there so this is a
different instruction set
other instruction sets aren't designed
to be subsetable they're
gigantic right yeah so if you want to
implement on v8 for example even if you
ignore the
the 32-bit stuff it's big and bloated i
mean it's it's monstrous
you know what i bet you know if you did
the study it would probably help
performance
a little bit and you would probably have
better spend your designer's time
on everything else like the micro
architecture and all that kind of stuff
rather than
verifying all those instructions so you
know
i really don't think there's you know
that wasn't the wise decision on that
part but that's okay
it's their project so anyway so in our
project um
just to go over the base so there are
some interesting differences we try to
be very vanilla at risk because
it works right there's no real you know
people seem to come back full circle to
this again and again and again
so the base is encoding the base is 32
bit fixed width naturally line
instructions
3200 registers plus x0's including x0
register um
rsr1 rs1 rs2 and the destination
register in fixed positions they don't
move around
magazine code decoding is simple we only
have a 12 bit of media in the base
format that was a very
conscious design decision 16 bit 16-bit
immediates are too big they ruin
the possibility of doing lots of
extensions simply um
we support ieee 2008 floating point so
there's also a full register format not
shown here to support that
and this very simple base isa supports
like i said pick dynamic linking a lot
of things you need for a modern
isa software stack okay um
uh just one thing the atomic operations
uh this is one of the standard
extensions this has
two categories of atomics one is amo so
fetch and up add
or max min kind of things on a single
word in memory
there's also the load reserve store
conditional style and with that we've
added
a forward progress guarantee for short
sequences of a certain size
now one new thing here is all the
atomics are annotated with two bits
uh acquire and release to support um
release consistency models which is
what's in the modern language
standards so that's actually built into
the isa support for this
if you set both bits it becomes strongly
strongly ordered
now transactional memory is an
interesting thing that we are interested
in but
i don't think the design is solid enough
to standardize it we've argued about it
at length over years
and not come up with something we're
happy with i think the industry still
hasn't quite figured that out yet but i
think that will happen we have a
extension reserved for that so as i
understand that you've
essentially not made a commitment to
your memory model you are embracing
all all useful memories no it's several
it's a relaxed memory model and this
this is how you uh there's a fence
instruction the base plus
pmo's kind of require release orderings
added to them so memory model is fixed
it's known
um it's defined that we've we've
committed that
okay um so now one thing that's
different from normal risk it has
supports variable length encoding and
this was a design in from the start
but the idea here was the base
instruction set you don't have to worry
about this they can all be 32-bit fixed
width for nitrogen-aligned
but we wanted to support both compressed
instructions and
variable length extended instructions to
support really big extensions
and so in the isa basically the low
2-bit so the 32-bit standard ones are
always
1-1 if they're 0-1 1 0-0-0 it's a
bit instruction there's also encodings
reserved for longer 48 64-bit and
basically
arbitrarily long instruction encodings
it's designed that those are in the
first
parcel 16-bit parcel you see so it's
easy for the instruction effects unit to
figure out the lens
right it's a design thing um
and the only impact this really has is
the base i say the branches and jumps
targets 16-bit
um granularity addresses so all the
branch and jump targets are 16 bit of
line that means you lose one bit of
range
in the base i say but in exchange for
that you get to
support these other things which you
think are very valuable um
in particular we've defined with in the
process of defining this compressed
instruction extension and what's really
nice about this compared to say the arms
or other people's things is you just mix
these in with the base i say
instructions
so when you add this extension in the
base 32-bit instructions now can be
only 16-bit aligned and you can mix in
the 16-bit instructions and nothing's
changing that base encoding for those
who don't know for example arm thumb 2
allows you to make 16-bit and 32-bit but
those 32-bit instructions are different
from the 32-bit only instructions
and those 16-bit instructions are
different from thumb 1 which had 16-bit
only instructions and all three of those
isas are supported by
on v7 cores and on v8 cores in addition
support the
64-bit instructions right anyway so
basically the model here is each
instruction 16-bit instruction
expands to a single regular instruction
and using this technique we get around
the 25
reduction in code size and the code size
is actually pretty good it's
smaller with this extension is quite a
bit smaller than x86
it's slightly bigger than thumb two a
few percent three percent kind of range
uh the reason is that we don't implement
load multiple store multiple
which are the if we had those we'd be
comparable to thumb too we decided those
caused some microarchitectural pain so
we didn't actually add those into the c
extension at least in the current draft
question um the c compressed instruction
set extension that you say is defined
here in chapter 13 which is
three sentences long so there's a much
fuller draft that will come out soon
there's actually a master's thesis that
has a prototype of it
which i've read right and and i had
concerns that a lot of the compression
gains would happen as you ventured down
to 8-bit instructions
and so i i at the end of it i
i thought it might need another pass
before
well we're putting out a draft for
comment um pretty soon
um we're working on the privilege the
first that's kind of the priority to get
that out um but the compressor will come
out shortly and the hope is to get the
community involved in defining this
now one thing is we're going to say no
to lots of suggestions already have but
we would love to get the input to make
sure we're not
missing something right um so
let's move on to the privileged
architecture that was the use level
architecture so
i view this as a place where there's
place a lot of space for innovation
let's say so i think reading through
lots of isa manuals this has been
incredibly messy
in most platform specifications and this
is reflected in
the complexity of say you know the
current operating system ports
so what we're trying to do in this is
provide a clean separation between the
layers of the software stack
and so there's some terminology we have
here that we sort of invented but let me
walk you through this so when you're in
an application
it's coded to an api an application
binary interface what is that that's a
combination of the instructions you can
use
plus calls out to the os right that's
kind of how the application does io
right and the application doesn't care
how those api calls are implemented
there's some what we call application
execution environment ae
implements the api that ae could be a
hardware platform
it could be software emulation it could
be you know some
virtualized thing somewhere else or just
a software simulator right the
application will still work correctly
provide you implement the api correctly
for the os
our plan is at supervisor level we're
not going to let the os touch the
hardware
it has a supervisor binary interface
that defines
in addition to the user level
instructions what extra privilege
instructions can it use
what does it mean and a supervisor
binary interface that says how it talks
to
the outer environment which is some
supervisor execution environment
okay now recursing down people like to
play with hypervisors so hypervisor what
is that is something that provides a
supervisor binary interface to an os
and we're not gonna let that touch the
hardware either so there's a hypervisor
buyer interface down to
a hypervisor execution environment now
so for example look at the os our goal
is not to have to do a power virtualized
os because no os will ever deal with
real devices
those will be handled out of the
platform you want to provide a very fast
i o
virtual i o style interface two os's
they'll have to discover
the devices but they won't be banging
bits in device registers right that
shouldn't have to happen
and i think if you look at the future of
slc's this is there's going to be
processes out there this can be handled
very different ways
i think we need to get away from um
having the os bit banging on device
register shouldn't do that the advantage
of doing this and our goal is a single
os image will run on any risk five
platform
just one image you won't have to
configure and set it up just one image
run everywhere
same with the hypervisor we do that
later
when is the stock oh maybe you're about
to answer that just you know if that
work
layers into the hypervisor and it stops
it stops where you want it to stop so
you i mean as long as the layers above
if you want to use an os you have to
provide a supervisor execution
environment you can choose how you want
to do that
um but the hardware in cases where
you're actually running this on native
hardware as opposed to
an emulation or simulation um it's going
to stop
at the hardware level and we're going to
hide the hardware between uh
behind a hardware extraction length and
this is similar to those you know for
the power code
a few differences between power code is
that our how code is mostly invisible to
those layers so things like emulating
missing instructions the how code
will take care of there's no direct
calls into it you should be going
through some
you know question mark bi some binary
interface to get the stuff you want to
do
so this really just hides most of the
hardware from these layers so for
example reset
where does reset happen it goes into the
how
everything else is some defined entry
point to that binary where you get
called once the system is set up
so this is again part of hiding the
platform details from
and we build and this is for our
research group we build test chips we
build fpga emulations we build
simulations
we offer this wide diversity of
platforms and
this is mostly for us but i think it's
what you need for all platforms
maybe not quite getting something so
where do device drivers
fit in are these down now device drivers
are effectively not part of the
operating system they're more part of
the sea or the hal
this level then hey they could be but so
things are the most important thing is
the os
just has an interface to them you can
package them how you see fit
we're actually looking at how to um
do iomu style define that so that hal
can reflect up
io cores to the os that it kind of
manages and knows about to do page
faults on
so the device drive itself could live
almost anyway a little bubble
that some layer outside the os will
install it
so i don't have time to go in there
we're still working on this design but
we want to
now one other thing you might say all
these layers this can be very
inefficient
but um part of the design is
although you talk about the hardware
direction you might think of that as
being far out in the
netherlands of the chip design this will
be in the core
and basically it's all about when you
take a trap where do you go what base
address
and what privilege mode and how is
translation happening at that point in
time so the hardware is going to vector
you to the right place at the right time
to avoid you know
jumping up and down through these layers
hopefully is the hardware abstraction
layer in a position
to prevent the its guest from bypassing
it
yes it can be in a platform you
implement it can be so
yeah are interrupts part of the sbi
so the only interrupts the os has a two
it has a timer interrupt and a software
interrupt
devices communicate through the software
interrupt which acts as a mailbox that
was the only two interrupts
the asp and the sbi the osc's
let's actually start here first um when
you're running on a zed board which i
notice you do
um do you use the same abstraction layer
when
we haven't implemented this yet we are
working towards it okay but but but i
presume the relationship between the
armed corps
on the zed board will take on the same
form well
so so you know i'm emulating things um
like for example this sbi all this part
below will be done by the
some combination of the arm cores the
fpga and the tethered thing that's
driving the zinc board
um this os won't have to care like where
it is
that's that's the goal this is a this is
a work in progress this is not complete
this is our design goal to bring this
out and the i o we want to
stay it's the intent yeah we're working
towards us so
okay um so currently the sort of
privilege back we're defining these four
supervisor
environments and the goal here is really
to support current popular
os's it's not right now to do supervisor
os
level research we just want to run
standard supervisor os's
and support them so in particular
there's a bare metal mode there's no
translation there's base and bounds mode
then there's these two
demand page 32-bit modes 32-bit virtual
address space 43-bit virtual address
space for 64-bit systems these are very
conventional
page systems yep sorry is virtual memory
an architectural thing or is that down
in the sdi
no the the os manages page tables it
doesn't see tlbs and it doesn't do tlb
flushes it has instead a fence on memory
management state
so there's a memory model around
touching the page tables what that means
so fence.mm means that from the next
instruction
we'll see the effect you just any rights
you've done to the the page table
structures the page table structures
defined
it can be done software hardware the os
won't get to do the software refill
it's um it does see the page table
format yes
and it sees supervisor physical memory
that it maps the supervisor uh to use a
virtual
question can you specify the page table
structure
yes
so the supervisor doesn't and we
designed the supervisor interface so it
doesn't know anything about being
virtualized this is one of the
virtualization goals
below that we can add a hypervisor that
has its own interface to things like
shut up we're not working on that that's
not something
we're going to do anytime soon people
want to look at that that'd be great um
we just want to make it clean so the
supervisor uh binary interface only sees
things the supervisor needs to worry
about
and as i said because we designed the
device interface this way
there's no sense of power virtualize
because it's it's always the same
there's no
this versus that you're kind of always
running power virtualized which means
power virtualize means nothing you're
always just virtualized in some sense
right
okay so again these are just designed to
support the current popular
os's these are not you know new things
the page table formats they're very
vanilla and that was deliberate just to
bring the current os is up
as guest the west is in here um
so there's a big ecosystem being built
up so risk5.org is the official website
that we've set up to
distribute stuff don't go looking at
other random berkeley websites we use
this in our classes the versions they
have over there are
hacks modified early drafts don't rely
on those to build anything
so as people have done and complain um
so risk five derogators official outlet
um so the privileged isolation come out
very soon
um software tools the whole canoe tool
chain lvm
linux some verification suite stuff to
run the zinc
software implementations including one
in javascript uh a reference golden
model spike in c plus plus and a qmu
port they're all
up there we have this hardware
implementation out rocket core soda
there's
actually a whole bunch of people around
the world building risk five
implementations
um and so just to show this this angel
thing
you know you can boot linux in a browser
so it implements the ris5 uh
isa and the old sort of supervisor state
in javascript
so anybody can run it in a browser it
runs about two mips we went to the
workshop last weekend there's somebody
who
gets this kind of thing running at 20
mips will probably steal all this good
ideas and have a 20 mips thing that runs
in your browser why would you want this
for teaching right you have a without
installing anything you can run this
stuff
in a browser and just run get things
going um qmu is much much faster so this
runs about
700 dry stone mips on a modern x86 this
is a you know
qmu's ginning technology and this is the
development environment of choice if you
want to develop os is on it
this is you know the qmu implementation
is by far the
most usable fastest risk five
implementation out there that's what you
should be pointing code to
um so we're writing all this all the
core
so risk five is a spec we actually are
doing an open source code we call rocket
and one difference there is a writing
this is in this new hardware description
language called chisel
uh which is uh the chisel the name
stands for constructing hardware in a
scala embedded language so here at
stanford mostly you know scala it's very
popular right here but it's a very
powerful modern language compiled to the
jvm
the nice thing is is functional plus
options oriented it's designed to
support embedded dsl so we embedded a
hardware dsl into scala
and you write a single chisel program
and from that you can generate a very
fast cycle accurate bit accurate
software simulator in c
plus or fpga ferrolog that you can use
for emulation or
basic barrel you can use to push through
and actually do chip designs
we've released this is all bsd open
source at chisel.exe.edu
we're working on our grand plans of
chisel 3.0 um
having worked with chisel for a while we
realized that what we really want to do
is build what we call the lvm for
hardware
we have the standard intermediate
representation we call fertile
fir rtl which is a flexible intermediate
representation for rtl
so fertile is going to be this internal
format you can write many passes for
this
and basically do transformations and
this will then make chisel just be a
front end
into which you come into fertile and you
can come in from other hyper description
languages as the plan
and use the tool or tool chain there yep
i
ran into some grumblings about the
literal declarations in scala
not being pretty which is to say they're
they weren't able to get the literals
and chisel to be the way you wish
is that going to get fixed in other
words is scalar getting revised to
address
i think scholar is adding stuff all the
time and we're tracking that
but there's a tension between making it
better and breaking
all the code we have okay um and it's
really improving our scala
gets better at supporting dsls okay
things like that might change but we
worry so actually going to 3.0 there's
one incompatibility with current
scala in the front end that we're going
to have to deal with
this is language design but it's very
powerful really helps us build lots of
cores
we use this in the classroom so there's
risk five in teaching there's a set of
cores you can go download called sodor
we use train names for all of our
processor cores at berkeley
and sodor is the island that thomas the
tank engine all these trains live on so
this is the educational cores
and one of the nice ones is actually a
little microcode engine we used to teach
people microcode
and in scholar itself we write a
microcode compiler so students can write
new microcode have it compile and run
and they can see it step through so they
can learn how microcode machines work
um we use this to build chips so we
built many risk 5
silicon artifacts in two lines of uh
chips one one project is about silicon
photonics actually but we're using it to
fabricate risk five cores we've done
fake five tape
out so far the last one is the cos 20.
it's a dual core
cash current design built from our chip
generator uh
runs linux um boots and releases a
photograph of the diet here's the two
risk five cores down here
this is one megabyte of sram this is a
bunch of experimental photonic links
this is kind of a block diagram what's
on there so there's a scalar core
vector core uh first level caches that
are kept coherent with a hub out here
so you know and this is the the fourth
tape out and we
keep doing these like every few months
we have tape outs of different risk five
cores we basically refine the
rtl as well as the you know playing with
the isa earlier on
um another pretty cool one is raven 3
this is in 28 nanometer fdsi
fd soi um and this is a cool project
that uses a
instead of using on-chip dc-dc converter
to power the chip
but instead of regulating the output
power which is what you would normally
want to do in a processor
we instead modulate the clock frequency
to track the instantaneous voltage
so we let the power supply ripple and
that the dc-dc
will switch here and then boost the
voltage again but as you can see the
clock gets slower as vdd decreases we're
doing very very fine grain
dvfs if you like within a dc dc
switching event
to raise efficiency um this is a part of
it here's the the core here is five core
with the vector unit
dc dc's are over here and this thing
these are actually scope traces actually
runs boots linux while all this is
happening
i'm getting over 30 gigaflops of what on
uh double precision matrix multiplier
actually running the code
this is double precision ieee you know
fuse moled
floating point unit right so this is the
rocket generator a different slightly
different system
how much did you gain in efficiency by
like
it's about it's actually difficult to
measure you have to figure out how to
measure it because you have to include
the
normally people measure dc dc's by
powering power out
but we want to measure it by work done
by the processor versus power in
so you have to factor in how accurate is
the clock tracking um
the the work uh the process in the
output but about 15 20
but the biggest gain is actually you
could have many of these on a chip
many dc dc levels many voltage levels
instead of having fewer off chip
supplies right that's actually the
biggest gain that thing actually runs
down to point four five volts
um that design um so rocket we released
last week
it's a classic single issue in order but
the dual issue is coming very soon it's
very similar like an arm
a5 right now will support something
similar to an rma7 you know it has a btp
bhd return address stack it's pretty
sophisticated simple core
it's designed to be an application
processor not a really stripped down
embedded core um because that's what we
wanted for our designs and it has a
co-processor interface to make it easy
to add accelerators on the side
um okay um so people keep asking how we
compared to arm
we did this little comparison just
because we couldn't you know
let people move on um so arm publishes
these numbers for
an a5 core that's with a certain
configuration no floating point unit
uh no neon we have to have access to the
same technologies we mapped our rocket
core
and basically with you know we're
smaller um
faster uh much lower power and with
64-bit instead of 32-bit
right now some of this is some stuff in
the arm core we don't have but there's
some stuff in our core they don't have
it's not a completely accurate
comparison
but just to give you a feel we're pretty
competitive um and uh
yeah so that's what it is
uh so we're not just doing it all the
course there's a student working on out
of water course we call boom berkeley
out of order machine
um this is a parameterized out of order
machine you can change issue with uh
functionalities that have attached um
you know this has been laid out it's
running a couple gigahertz
uh um and you know at some point this
will be open source once we get more of
the bugs out it kind of runs most of
spec in right now but there's still some
bugs
working through it it's actually hard to
design an out of order core that
performs better than an inaudible that's
what we found you have to get a lot of
things right
to have it really fly how long does it
take to run the chisel job to compile
this
um it's got a lot better just recently
it did take a long time there was a very
dumb pass in the chisel compiler
it turned out using a very bad algorithm
talking about algorithms
it's since i think it's uh minutes or so
but remember this that just generates
the verilog getting to this stage you
have to run through all the vlsi flow
so that takes hours to get through to
get the layout
um so external users um there's
folks in the uk who are building socs
they're gonna involve production they
have a private sponsor
and these are some of the folks who did
the raspberry pi before some of those
founders of raspberry pi are doing this
and the goal is education and to get
people hacking hardware again
and the private sponsor once that's his
gold while he's funding this project
um they're basing that on the risk five
cores um
blue spec in the u.s can company they're
actually selling people or giving people
there's five cores that customers wanted
a simple core to include
so they just use rs5 or the tool chain
is there the government of india
some reason has decided that risk five
is the national isa
for india so
they they had their own projects
political reasons
no so there's just two reasons you don't
realize one is
the indian government is looking at um
their gdp and their imports
and what they're seeing is as a fraction
of their imports seven conductors are
rising to become unsustainable
they need their own semiconductor
industry that's one thing
the other thing is they are worried
about security in uh the defense systems
so they want to use
have their own core they control to do
this
and so more and more people are starting
starting to hear about people using this
um so to help build the community a
couple of things will be happening one
is a
we'll be setting up a nonprofit
foundation to
promote manage the isa uh help people
implement it um
support the people implementing it um
we're gonna have the first risk five
workshop january 14th 15th this is going
to be in
monterey the marriott there it's
free to all academics faculty students
anywhere
all the affiliates of our aspire lab and
it's open to anybody for
99 which basically almost covers the
food bill
so we'll feed you well um you can
register online at this address
if you just go to risk5.org it's all you
can get to it there it's filling up fast
surprisingly fast and it's first come
first serve
you know um so sign up soon um
and it's about all i have uh here just
want to end with this is one part of the
aspire lab and this is what we call our
lasagna stack
this is all the projects going on in
aspire and this is about 11 faculty and
about 50 to 60
grad students so risk five kind of
evolved from this and actually it's the
core of a lot of the
work people do at berkeley we actually
all work together uh
on these big projects and actually work
together um and risk five is the core
infrastructure all this stuff is uh
based around
okay i just want to thank all the people
who actually paid for all this um
and i should have assigned all the many
students but uh that'll be quite long
there's actually about
i'd say three or four core students plus
another five or six who contribute quite
regularly to it
uh you'll be building all this plus now
expanding set of people outside or
actually starting to get contributions
back
from the community okay so thanks
ten years from now this has completely
taken over the world it has
replaced the intel instruction set and
the arm instruction set
can you visualize today what sequence of
events would happen
that would lead to that or before with a
lot of missing steps there's one
steps today and then a miracle happens
no i think i think that
um the possible beachheads for this i
say
are the very small and the very big
basically where the incumbents
aren't incumbent so servers is x86 will
be for a while
just like 360s at mayframes um
you know it's mobile's tablets is on and
will be for a while despite what intel
would like
right neither of these guys can really
make my opinion these aren't going to
make substantial beach heads into the
guy's story
so i think the beach heads are at the
very low end of things the iot and
there's a lot of companies out there who
have great ideas for iot
and the hardware is only a small part of
the story so the services and everything
else
they would like chips that are
customized and cheap they cannot deal
with arm
it's impossible to do anything with
intel so they're kind of stuck
and we hear from these people
increasingly that we need something and
we want the whole software stack
right and that's that's the story the
other extreme is the very big the data
center guys
you know they're gonna need 128 bits
sometime every address-based change
isas change that seems to be a rule of
the industry
right so um i think the very big guys
have special needs they also want to
control their destiny
one of the reasons this arm is popular
in the service space isn't because of
the power efficiency implementations
that's just that's just the red herring
the important thing is customers can
take that and add their own stuff
they cannot do that with off-the-shelf
x86 stuff you might see intel pushing
the fpga plus x86 that's kind of their
way of getting around that for their
customers but really
the big guys i think want to do their
own custom socs these data centers to do
special source you know whatever and
they can't do that with the intel thing
that's what they're using arm
they'll be much happier not to deal with
arm r makes it very difficult to
there's only 15 companies with an
architectural license who are allowed to
implement an arm code it has to be
compatible with arm
they cannot extend it and they cannot
design something and then sell it to a
third party
the other options you license the arm
cores arm has and that's it
and those are not very good for like you
want to base an accelerate off them you
can't do that and so what people do
is they hand roll their own isa and
accelerator and then they get killed by
the software cost that's why all these
hardware startups die
because they do their own i say because
they think they have to because
everybody else is proprietary
they get killed by the software support
cost that's a really dumb thing to do
they should base it off a standardized
say that's open
add their secret source that can be
proprietary we don't care um but they
would
not have to rebuild you know gcc and bin
utils and all this junk uh
every time around um yep so i think
that's the beach head there's lots of
people just
doing it this this way and eventually
who knows that
you know future will be something other
than phones and tablets
denver core originally it was tart
it was going to run the x86 instruction
set and they had a falling out and now
it's
emulating arm have they looked at
tuning the denver core to run your iso
i don't think so um it'd be nice if they
did i think
one other project is people often ask
why did you define a native isa and not
a virtual machine
to get at this question a little bit um
i think the answer is it can't be
turtles all the way down you actually
need and i say
implementing hardware and the reason is
going back is the cost of implementing
that translation layer from one
level to another is very high the
security issues with doing that how
trustworthy is that optimizing compilers
doing all that stuff that's non-trivial
your trusted code base just balloons
when you do that um
so actually what i'm interested in is
looking at things like the jv and
replacing the jvm
and you know what if this runs
everywhere you don't actually need
a virtual machine you just need a
different slightly different api and
risk five would be
would be the vm that would run
everywhere with a few bindings that will
help it to help support
managing languages and other features
you want to have in a vm but then the
hardware implementation will be very
simple you know most instructions run
natively
um on most implementations you just have
to have a you know risk five to x86
converter so you can run on legacy
hardware
you know leave the whole thing yep uh
your um
uh low-risk friends in cambridge have
been talking to
our colleagues in the university of
cambridge
uh watson and brian right uh about
the uh possibility of your
uh or their integrating some of our uh
cherry uh capability architecture into
uh into risk five right i was wondering
whether you're familiar with any of that
yeah so i i was just in cambridge last
week talking to those folks
so um very familiar i'm on their
advisory board so i know what they're
doing
um so they um i think what will happen
is
uh as the privileged spec they already
have a copy of the very
unsuitable for mass release privilege
back and looking at it um
their cherry stuff will be added as sort
of extensions onto one of the virtual
memory
uh supports and the is folks the most
likely thing is they will make that
you can enable disable the capability
stuff so you can run the soc just as a
standard linux box or run this stuff on
top
so yeah that's great so this was meant
you know there's meant to be a standard
that you can rely if you just so there's
different communities some people just
want a core they can take use all the
software works
another community wants to take all this
stuff and change it right and that's
great we did that we
we're researchers we want to encourage
that right doing trying all these
different things out
and so yeah so the user isa supports
extensions the privilege that i say also
supports extensions we want to provide
that yep you touched on the
hardware interface and device discovery
do you have any commitments in that
direction on how you interface with
existing hardware
pci devices and how
do you have any ideas on the impacts on
firmware
like acpi right so um
i think our goal as it has been the rest
of the risk five is to try and do the
right thing
and figure out how that interfaces with
the old stuff one thing to realize is as
people move to slc's
a lot of that stuff is you know pci is
going to be important right it's a
pretty important step ethernet is going
to be important
but a lot of the other stuff you can
change it on the slc and you're going to
want to change it for security reasons
and performance like when you're talking
100 gigabit enough ethernet you kind of
need to do things pretty differently
um another thing is we have been talking
to the linux
the mainline developers and one thing i
should say is most of the
relevant tools are going to be
mainstream sometime soon we've been
talking to all the people in these
different branches or software tools
so the linux guys in particular the guys
supporting the non-x86 arm soc world
they really really would like us to make
it cleaner so one thing if you risk five
hours a test bed for trying out
you know how to move everything else
forward because we can be more
experimental
and i think we want to uh work with the
linux guys to figure out how to make the
i o
extremely clean and work with all these
standard interfaces in particular
yeah so we've been talking to people
about you know things like uefi open
boon or like that space of things
that's down at the house so it shouldn't
affect most of the stack
um and that's one of the goals is to
isolate it from
um these other things but yeah we're
thinking about what would be our
preferred thing so i think what we'll be
defining is
how you would if you want to build this
kind of hardware platform this is how
you build it this is how it should boot
things like that so it
address is playing with rapid io i guess
because it's open and maybe not
constrained by
the pci license issues pci express is
obviously
intel's likely well i think rapid io
builds on
uh well this okay the protocol doesn't
but a lot of implementations do
so yeah rapid io we looked at that as
for the firebox project
um it's uh not as powerful
as we'd like it's better than pci for
connecting things it's definitely better
than pci switches
it's not as powerful as what we'd like
to do for firebox but i view that that's
an i o
you know issue so i think we need to
first figure out for these different
classes of
io how we want to support it in these
abstraction layers then we can go start
talking about that's more stretching out
into
hardware standards rather than interface
then
they are working with arm there's a
there's a working group on using rapid
ao for very large
systems and the madras guys and arm and
various other people involved in this
working group
on extending rapido to very large very
large
um have systems talked to the cloud
computing companies and if so what have
they told you
uh they're very they're very supportive
i mean they would like to help with the
foundation for example why are they
supposed to do what
why are they supporting it i don't know
maybe they would like
openness openness i mean so for example
the facebook guys the open compute
foundation you know they're very
interested in this
you know they would like to i think
remember this is not
uh about open source necessarily it's a
specification
that you can have proprietary
implementations for and you can decouple
the industry this is a very powerful
thing our industry always
you know thrives on standards so you
allow more players in
you get innovation um i think it's vital
i mean i think
in i say the proprietary ones are
holding us back i think actually you
know my thoughts aren't costing benefits
of a formal standardization process
a formal spec is a very good thing and
we've been talking to people at
cambridge about doing a formal spec
including the memory model that's a
great thing something like ieee
i think it's a great thing for somebody
else to go do
all right sorry so i have a couple of
questions actually so
you mentioned about the complexity and
the issues around the environment
more than that yeah
yeah sure i mean i think the the what we
hear back so we're surprised at
we present this stuff with naive
academics you know we hear that maybe
harm's an issue for some people
you know lots of whisperings in the ear
about what actually goes on and i think
one of the
surprises to us it can take up to two
years to negotiate the royalty rate
so in this industry two years is like
eternity right right um
also um the upfront cost and also they
just won't give licenses to everybody
just because you have the money they
won't necessarily give you a license
because there's a strategic component of
who get like especially architectural
licenses
even if you have the money they won't
give you a license and even if you have
the money and they give you the license
you cannot extend it i say in a way you
want to make it visible to anybody else
you have to pass the compatibility stuff
so there's these constraints that people
are unhappy with
that said it's a big ecosystem there's
lots of people very happy with it like
my first few slides
if it fits your model and you can
negotiate with them you'd be crazy not
to use it it's a very well engineered
tightly coupled system lots of people
like it
but i would say if you're really
innovating and want to differentiate
yourself
it's very hard in your ecosystem to do
that the second
second question i have is it's about
security
you know what is gx for example yeah
things like that so what's your strategy
in that thing
because it seems like it's one of the
advantages that clean up
and can have if you if you take into
account
this community and then impress you so i
think i think we've actually in the
privilege that is a we've observed a
level for what we call trusted mode and
we haven't really expanded on that much
beyond preserving a piece of the
encoding space um
i think like transactional memory is
something that's still very much
research i think one of the
hopes is are i say simple enough that it
will help
designing the virtualization levels and
the
just keeping it simple will help with
some other security that
one factor in security i don't
i think there's a lot of challenges in
security design i don't know if all the
current solutions are great you know
like the end goal
so but i'm hoping we can experiment with
those in this
framework and some people are like the
cambridge guys are they're adding
capabilities for example
um their particular take on a particular
security attack
thoughts on how we will manage uh
incompatible
uh uses of the instruction set in
compatible extensions
right there's a chapter in the ic mine
it talks about managing extensibility so
general policy
is you know we're going to have these
things that have blessed the standard
extensions there's these
few we've said so far and they're
guaranteed not to conflict in the coding
space you know they're designed to laid
out that way
and future standard ones will also not
conflict in the encoding space
we call something that something else a
non-standard extension you're happy to
define that however you wish
and the only thing we require is that if
you implement
any of the standard ones they have to be
in the standard place in the coding
space
so that means all the tools will just
work and they won't even know about the
other junk you've added into the isa
now if you want to standardize it one
thing we said is you package all your
isa extensions into
a portion of the encoding space so we
can easily change the prefix
you may have a research prefix that you
where you're experimenting with the isa
extensions you do it all that
you should only have to change its
prefix to remap it to a different part
of the encoding space
and to pack it you know but it's like
you'll get allocated at some point if it
becomes popular people agree
a standard prefix i'll make sure it
doesn't collide and what we hope to do
is provide tools that make it easy for a
custom embedded implementation
you can just cherry pick all the pieces
you want and package them together and
maybe reduce the instruction length
um so the ones you want are all the ones
you need and they you can package those
and have the tools generate that
so for the embedded space that would be
so i think again to realize there's
different customers there's the embedded
guys who want
you know the software will never be
extended by anybody else versus the
general purpose development
software development define a mechanism
as part of the architecture so uh people
can test for the existence of extensions
so it's really easy to tell if your
machine has particular extensions
it's the api and spi it's not hardwired
in that shouldn't be part of the
machine registers now all the way down
some layer may look at registers to
figure it out but it's
from the guest os perspective it
integrates the spi to figure out what's
there
because you want to lie about it
sometimes
yeah jvm is being ported with help from
oracle
so um but like i said i view the jvm as
yet another proprietary i say
so um i'm actually interested in seeing
how we use ris5 to replace the jvm but
a lot of software needs a jvm and so we
are it's
being brought up one of the problems
with open source is that it can be hard
to control it
and we saw this with units where we had
this wonderful operating system but then
10 vendors took it
and they all evolved in different
directions they ended up with a tower of
babel and that was one of the reasons
why windows was able to beat them all
because there were all these different
versions of unix
uh give thoughts about what would keep
that from happening with
risk five because manufacturers would be
tempted to try and take it and add their
own proprietary thing on it to
make it better well two things one is um
you can't say swiss five compatible
unless the foundation says so
second one is um we've already frozen
part of the reason we didn't come out
until now is we now finally froze in the
isa spec
so the user level basic stuff you know
you can't change that and
yeah it's that's frozen so they can add
stuff and that's it's a goal to allow
people to add stuff
but the challenge would be if some
company came along and said we're going
to add some very important new
instruction
that you absolutely need to run the
latest whiz-bang app or set of apps
right and we're going to like license
you know encumber this in some way that
requires
you to lock into us and the hope is the
community just rejects that
uh is the hope can you keep people from
effectively patenting new instructions
on the
risk 5 v2 architecture so panzer a good
good point to bring up so we believe the
isa itself does not have anything that
requires
infringing a patent now of course once
you build a microarchitecture
there's a gazillion microarchitecture
patterns you might infringe
however a lot of the good ideas in out
of order super scalar architecture were
published
20 years ago or more and so they are
patent expired
so if you go re-implement a mips r20k
exactly the same you know you can read
the published things how it happens so a
lot of the old patents on
stuff is expired now actually quite keen
for one thing the foundation can do is
provide an umbrella to protect people
implementing risk five by documenting
the prior art for all the stuff that's
there
so to say this stuff is safe to use
because of these these things and um
and hopefully with enough 800 pound
gorillas on our side we can defend
against
the trolls um is the hope yep one of the
things i like about alpha is they
attempted
uh really hard to define all the
boundary cases unpredictable and defined
obviously they have been taken out
bridge
yes so isn't that isn't there a tension
between that and extensions
um no i mean each instruction is defined
and then extensions have to
the extension also has to define things
like one one of the things we spent some
time on is
the os handling extended user state from
new extensions at the
user level and we provide there's a
part of the status register encodes the
um
like normally in a system you have a fpu
enable bit because the os doesn't want
to save and restore the phone point
registers if no
you're not actually using them we kind
of extended that a bit to have a
four state model of off clean sorry off
initial
clean and dirty um there's some one set
of bits of the fpu one set of bits for
anything else
plus instructions that can save and
restore initialize an opaque object
that's the
user context so
that's to insulate the os from user
extensions um so they said
they could separate out so you'd have to
change the os binary to add user
extensions
like you can save everything else and it
will save it for you
now that won't actually be implemented
as a hardware instruction in most
platforms it'll be empty by the how
so you want the oso only has to allocate
space
to say restore this and in addition that
instruction may do internal
micro architectural optimizations you
don't have to know about either an
example doing this way back when was the
vector vax actually had this
exact same structure to save and store
the vector unit state without
they always have to know about it um so
it's an old idea that so one thing is
there's all these great old ideas and
i'm quite happy to
use these great old ideas because you
know when they work they work you don't
have to
invent new things yep load multiple uh
which we're just talking about saving
restoring vector state obviously
local this brings back to the the save
restore primitive
uh wanting to be compact in the
instruction stream to save space
and bandwidth yeah we argue about a
little multiple store multiple i think
that's one of those
things and then we fall we tend to form
the side of simplicity
um and that's what we've done so far
yep so do you have something or do you
plan for something like concentric
instruction extension language to
formalize or proceed with my
instruction extension well yeah so we
have chisel
and we've already have in fact in
classes like right now students are
taking class with the adreno
accelerators to the rocket core
they're doing it by manually writing the
rtl and chisel for those accelerators
right now
but you know for no reason you couldn't
replicate the tensolico style
environment uh if you wanted to um
so yeah and actually tends to look
another interesting case study so
you know why would you do a 24-bit
instruction length
there are good reasons to it's a lot of
thousands
so if you have 16 and 32 i don't think
you need 24 that's what i would say
um but it you know it's a big barrier
and also
you know wouldn't that life be much
easier if they had a standard assays to
start from and the real technology isn't
a risk i say the real technology is you
know tie and all this stuff
so they reinvented the wheel you know
and that's a small company you don't
want that pain
um early in your talk
you said well let's look at existing
there's x86
there's our this doesn't work and that
doesn't work
so let's choose this instead of this
thing there must have been 20
30 well-defined well-documented
well-implemented
architectures over the last 30 years how
hard did you
examine all the others before jumping
straight to the thing you've done 20
years ago so you can do it first check
is it open no that narrows it down to
a handful
so about that handful why didn't they
succeed
is it because they're extensible so
actually this is i've been having spent
the weekend in munich talking to the
open course guys um
um and then being made aware of many
more open calls i've been looking around
i think the biggest single floor is
they're not really architects
surprisingly the people they they
they're what i call stuck in 1940s 1950s
architecture where the
core is the isa and we're like a decade
ahead we're like in the 60s you know
with the ibm 360 where you separate the
isa from implementation i think that's
one
thing they haven't you know that and
also it's a lot of hobbyists which is
great and we'll encourage those
guys but i think the biggest single
drawback is most those isas were
designed as a single implementation that
was documented
and they haven't thought of the
separation yep if you're not going to
use the intel or the arm instructors
that there's no particular advantage in
using any one of these other has been
because they have no market share
no particular penetration this will
benefit from that you might as well do
something that's better
which is a 24-bit machine okay and um
and have some views with respect to uh
memory use efficiency
and packing and unpacking ease the load
store architecture should
allow loading and storing of 24-bit
quantities and
should be independent of address
alignment we already know
that you've uh you support misaligned
32 instructions because of the hack
packing
right why not carry that a little bit
further and make
your memory interface alignment agnostic
and be able to milk even more from your
ability to pack and unpack as you go in
and out of memory
well two things so one thing is the
memory system is bite addressable that's
kind of one of the
some parts of software are very hard to
change that assumption is very hard to
change as the alpha guys found out
right do you have a load 24 bit or a
load no
so then i'd say then
you're accessing memory and byte level
quantities if you want to add an
extension that loads up
you know n times whatever width vector
and treats it go ahead you know
there's plenty of encoding space to
write all that stuff i think
for most general use having all the
powers of two you're never more than the
factor of two off
in fact you're always less than a factor
two off the ideal size and for most
people have found over the years
that's kind of okay and if you take your
example 24 bits it's at most fifty
percent
it's fifty to thirty percent better and
yeah so if that's important your
application go build the engine that
uses those bits
um and you won't be able to use a
standard c compiler to generate code for
it
without breaking i see that same engine
as being able to pack op codes using
inline arguments in other words
now you can use the program counter
that you're calling from to fetch your
immediate operands
so basically all of the fancy packing
would be supported in terms of being
able to to
fetch some number of bytes into into a
register there's a whole big gain in
both the instructions
say 36 bits are here to stay well
and they had a point you know uh len
bozak and sanders
advise you don't listen to him i don't
think you will anyway because no matter
where you put your point it's always
going to
no matter where you put your interface
somebody's going to say oh let's just
add this one little thing it's not that
much more complicated
just go off the deep end so yeah so like
the right thing yeah we always fall on
the side of i mean dave is
part of the group so he's very he keeps
reminding us simplicity is king
and we have a one page that green card
that dave did while he was
you know laid out i guess he had some
spare time they had a very nice one-page
summary of instruction set
and it's very simple unlike the 5000
page
i might say manual we can actually
describe the whole isa on a single sheet
of paper
there's no one has yet tried to write a
armed v8 book
and i know why now it's it's gigantic
right oh they're working they just know
they're only five years into the project
so i mean and so simplicity like if you
think about security for example like
the verification costs and security
verification also you want things you
always want things to be simple but even
more so these
i think it's just uh and there's no
reason
the quantifiable performance gain is in
the noise when you consider
in the background of all these other
factors that affect the efficiency of a
system
one thing you might look at is is the
formal method stuff that we've embedded
the sri
proof tools and smt solvers and
stat solvers into the blue spec
compilation channel
chain so we can actually do analysis of
the
uh blue spec hardware isa
and improve properties about it for
example uh yeah
i think i i am very excited that people
want to build a formal model and then
you first need to spec and then that
would enable tools like this
so you could have formally verified
implementations i mean that has been
done a few times before
um it would be good to have that i think
a lot of last time we tried if we were
40 years ahead of this thing right now i
think it's done it's
possible yeah the nice thing is if
there's only one i say you don't so we
do it all the time
so so you said we said no
to various ideas did you document those
so if you read the isa manual there's an
extensive rationale behind our choices
there's a lot of there's a lot of we
spend a lot of time writing why we
didn't do certain things it's incredibly
important i mean
both for sort of reading between the
lines and understanding what actually
did happen but also
for uh saving energy when somebody comes
along and suggests
well there's a master's thesis on the
compressed instructions and that
corresponded with the
chat who wrote that thesis and he says
you're one of the few people who's read
the thesis
i mean you know one thing you know as
many of you your innovators know
but you have an idea everybody knows
that it's bad without having understood
it at all
and there's a people are good at
throwing tomorrows without understanding
the thing so but we took care
we can right not dfm like we wrote it
all down
once you've read it then you know please
come talk to us and you know you might
disagree with us
the sections what do you call it
commentary yeah commentary
and so when you get to like load start
multiple
though there's a discussion about all
the issues
right all the things we considered so
yeah
let me do listen to input like the the
memory model the
amo ordering bits arose after people
have pointed out well we should have
better support than the fence
instruction the fence instruction would
have been adequate
for supporting the language models but
given that we're adding the mos
as an extension and that it seemed very
easy to
add these things that that was added on
the basis of feedback from outside about
people who are implementers of those
languages telling us you know you need
to think about this
a bit more than you have i mean what you
have is okay but this would be better
there's some things we left out that
people complain about i think
one we hear a lot about is overflow uh
checking for overflow
it turns out one of the good things in
the isa is is merge branch compares and
the branch themselves
and you'll see that mips has done that
now even more so these have just
registered quality
i think that's so what might be
interesting to write is what do people
have
the conversions of what the risk is a
new set of things that are different
from maybe the original risk i says
so we could probably write that um but
because we
added the compares into the branches we
can do unsigned interflow over check in
a single branch after the you know
before the ad even
so or after the ad so the only one that
we can't handle cleanly is a signed
integer ad overflow that takes a few
instructions
but you know how many languages need
that you know there are so many
languages
popular ones that neither that's the one
thing you know that's one thing that
comes up that maybe
and we decided to err on the side of
simplicity because it is a
slightly awkward branch to implement yep
there's a premise here that simplicity
is good
and quick design is good and quick
design cycle is good and
even better if six grad students can do
it in the semester and so forth
um as a user of a computer system
why do i care how how much trouble the
manufacturers do
why do i care if intel put 5000 man
years into getting a processor out
if the result is something that in some
way is more useful to me a couple
reasons
one is you paid for it
you paid for those engineers if you're a
server like why do the data center guys
want to do something else and
intel have you bought have you looked at
the price of a server chip from intel
um other thing is security
how likely is this thing to actually
work um
and also understanding it like if you're
a compiler author
aaa okay as a user my premise is
somebody that wants to buy a system i'm
not a compiler right
sure i the uh but no so you're right as
an end user just
so but look you know think about how
many more iot devices will be out there
if they're all waiting to license stuff
from um
we're at a change point in the industry
when we're going away from chips to socs
and so that is a fundamental change
where people can
cuss you're not just buying a chip from
intel and they're making 100 million of
them and it doesn't cost you anything
now that people lots of companies
deciding socs
that will be real costs verification
costs will be real cost
and it'll affect the cost of these socs
and it's a
you need to have a different set of
requirements for soc
construction system maybe maybe a more
refined answer to you paying for it is
that
um intel's model relies on this sort of
business economy class you know servers
and everything else
but to pay for the core development they
charge the server guys a lot of money
and also they don't get to because it's
such a complex core it's hard to build
an slc around it like
it lets somebody else build an slc
around it so you're limited by what
intel thinks the good socs right now
um so you you know like apple for
example you know why they get such
battery life they integrate a lot of
stuff they do the whole
vertical integration they couldn't do
that with well they might be able to
persuade intel now
uh they want to use that but it's too
late that ship sail through intel so
you know there's you do care even if you
do care because you pick these other
products that don't have x86 in now for
example
you